hallo liebe leute und viele grüße aus
münster hier haben wir diese woche mit
meiner familie weihnachten gefeiert und
wir senden euch schöne grüße diese woche
haben wir leider kein super easy german
video für euch denn wir haben sehr viel
gefeiert freunde verwandte besucht und
da hatten wir keine zeit 1 zu drehen
aber wir haben dieses kleine video für
euch es ist nur in deutsch ohne
untertitel
es ist eine übung für euch ich spreche
langsam und ihr könnt testen ob ihr mich
versteht wenn ihr lust habt könnt ihr
auch dieses video transkribieren und
übersetzen
postet es in den kommentaren und ich
werde euch dann korrigieren
heute haben wir eine kleine ankündigung
für diejenigen von euch die in vietnam
wohnen wie ihr wisst hat manuel gerade
eine weltreise gemacht oder er macht
jetzt eine weltreise erfährt für zwei
jahre mit seiner freundin um die welt
und wir haben ihn im sommer getroffen
und ihn interviewt zwischendurch hat er
uns ein video aus indien geschickt und
in zwei wochen werden wir ihn
wiedersehen in vietnam wir also ja schon
ich fahren nach vietnam und wir möchten
euch dort treffen
wenn ihr lust habt uns zu treffen könnt
ihr hier unten einen link finden für ein
google formular und dort könnt ihr euch
eintragen und was möchten wir in
wittener machen drei sachen erstens wir
möchten ein video drehen über
unterschiede zwischen vietnam und
deutschland
wir möchten gerne deutsche in vietnam
treffen deutsche muttersprachler und
auch leute die deutsch lernen
dafür benötigen wir kontakte zu
deutschen institutionen deutschen firmen
oder einfach deutschen die ihr kennt die
in den armen leben
wir fahren nach herne in den norden für
eine woche und nach ho chi minh city in
den süden
für eine woche wenn ihr menschen kennt
die wir interviewen können in unserem
video
schreibt uns unbedingt zweitens wir
möchten euch treffen die easy german
zuschauer
wir möchten einen mieter ab machen so
wie wir es auch in berlin machen und
zwar in hanoi und ho chi minh city
wenn ihr kommen möchtet oder eine idee
habt für einen ort zb eine kneipe oder
ein restaurant
schreibt uns unbedingt und drittens was
war drittens ianus drittens wir möchten
natürlich auch vietnam angucken wir
möchten gerne vietnam sehen die beiden
städte kennenlernen und die umgebung
kennenlernen und janosch möchte gerne
mit jemandem vor ort in kontakt kommen
der uns alles zeigt wenn ihr lust habt
uns für einen nachmittag zu begleiten
oder mit uns einen ausflug zu machen
zeigt ihr uns vietnam und wir sprechen
zusammen deutsch und üben deutsch
schreibt uns wir freuen uns auf euch das
war unser kleiner gruß aus münster von
aus der weihnachtszeit und wir freuen
uns jetzt auf eure kommentare und auf
eure nachrichten schreibt uns und
nächste woche am sonntag diesen sonntag
gibt es wieder ein normales video für
euch
bis bald ich gehe jetzt mit meinem vater
ein buch lesen
hallo papa was liest du denn da ach ja
das war einst das deutsche vereinsrecht
ist sehr interessant kann man mal
gelesen so zu weit
ja das ist auch eine gute lektüre